London has fallen is the sequel to the
surprisingly successful Olympus has
fallen and once again it stars Gerard
Butler as the greatest Secret Service
agent ever protecting the president
played by Aaron Eckhart in London when
terrorists attacked the city tried to
assassinate the president as well as
other leaders who are present for this
big funeral Olympus has fallen I
actually enjoyed I liked that first film
largely because of Antoine Fuqua
direction he directed a fairly tense
movie and it also had a lot of
comparisons to die hard 5 because it
came out at just the right time a couple
months after the highly disappointing
die hard 5 a lot of people viewed
Olympus has fallen as the die hard 5 we
didn't get with this film there's some
good and some bad now the director's
name is the back Najafi I largely
enjoyed the way he directed this film
the action was mostly well handled there
are some very poorly edited sequences
though involving a car chase under a
bridge where like this guy knocks the
door off the car and then pops out of
the window and starts shooting now this
would all be fine and dandy if key
moments weren't missing from the editing
room for some reason it was like this
cut doors flying off cut ban he's
already out the window what like what
happened during that time period the
large majority of the action though is
mostly passable the best sequence
towards the end is made to look like one
take and that's the thing lately
directors like to do that ran do this
thing in one take make look like one
take you can tell where the cuts are
somebody jumps through some smoke and
the smoke obscures the frame for a while
and then you know we get into our next
shot but it's still the same shot they
want you to think that anyway the last
20 minutes or so I did find very
entertaining from an action standpoint
but up until then it was mostly just
fine and I would say that word pretty
much describes my entire feeling for
this movie it was fine it was alright it
wasn't anything special it wasn't as
good as the first one the first one was
just enjoyable you know it wasn't like
this great thing it was just kind of a
mindless action movie that felt sort of
like it came out in 1997 or something
and this film has that vibe as well
trust me people are going to overanalyze
this films politics and say things like
it's overly patriotic and all these
kinds of things without realizing that
it's just a mindless action movie made
to make audiences go yeah a couple times
that's really all London has fallen is
and sometimes it succeeds Gerard Butler
is really good in the movie I thought he
did well in the action scenes he was
funny he was likeable his interplay with
Aaron Eckhart was also very good it is
highly forgettable though and that's I
think its biggest flaw this movie is
incredibly disposable you can watch it
maybe like on a rainy day I wouldn't
really recommend seeing this in theaters
this movie is just fine if you have
nothing else to do and it comes on TV or
maybe you pick up the blu-ray one day
from some rental box store slash Netflix
whatever that is probably where this
film will be appreciated the most that
being said walking out of this movie
someone came up to me and said hey Chris
would you think the movie in a way
that's all right and this older lady
next to me went just alright
yeah I mean you know I thought it was
alright you know different opinions and
stuff well that's true so you know some
people are really gonna like this movie
and think it's the best movie ever made
but you know it's alright I'm gonna give
London has fallen a C+ and please stay
tuned for this Sunday for my retro
rewind of Superman 64 i'm gonna try to
play that game one of the worst video
games ever made and I'm going to record
myself doing it I hope you guys enjoy
that also dear Chris my hero I thought
you may like these official rare norm of
the North socks enjoy
Justin Curtis this made me laugh my ass
off thank you so much for sending these
I'll never wear them but I will look at
them often and laugh and I did get your
other package as well but that had some
personal stuff in it so I didn't know if
you wanted me to say that in the video I
did get a Pio box finally guys you've
been asking me to do that for a long
time and that is p.o box 1028 Cuyahoga
Falls Ohio four four two two three you
can address it to myself Chris Stockman
or my wife Sam Liz and trust me I'm not
expecting anything really free like
don't send me you don't have to send me
anything really I don't care it's
entirely for fun stuff like this this is
hilarious it made me laugh you guys are
the best thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes